[Applause]
[Music]
okay everyone welcome to channel awesome
Zorba report your source for everything
happening around the world in pop
culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Bruce and I'm Ayanna wave
and this is your news for Monday May 7th
first of all there was a ton of stuff
that was happening this week we saw like
a ton of new trailers so we can't get it
all covered right now for you but we did
pick two that we're gonna talk about
right now six trailers and the first one
is one that the internet is generally
disappointed with and that is the new
trailer for Robin Hood who I do not
blame them yeah not look great I said it
kind of seems like it has an element of
Assassin's Creed it's like someone
thought you know what school Assassin's
Creed no one else's the kids like these
days that arrow show on the CW you know
we should do put it together to make it
confusing amalgamation of action with
maybe some social justice commentary
thrown is like super a historical cause
like the costumes are not going on with
historically accurate obviously oh but
like also that combat was weird the art
3 was soft and super weird just the
concept as a whole I'm not really sure
I'm understanding it great great I think
it seems like they're trying to go for a
traditional Robin Hood story but also
add something new by like having all of
the people rise up with him and it
doesn't look great but a lot of really
odd things happening in the trailer well
and it's Taron Egerton who was Kingsman
great and Jamie Foxx also great so I
don't know what happened with the rest
of that maybe it's just a bad trailer
maybe maybe maybe
I'm not gonna hold out too much hope but
we got a little bit before that comes
out it doesn't come out until November
so wait till November to see what that's
actually going to be like but hopes are
not high hopes are not high hopes are
high however for this next trailer which
is the ant-man and the wasp trailer yeah
which was great
I think it's just a really solid trailer
well edited well paste also I appreciate
that this team-up of those two gets the
song it takes to set to it and I also
really liked using the truck as like a
scooter yeah this is sort of like that
comedy relief we need it after Infinity
Ward's mom no spoilers but you know you
know or you don't know when you will
know but who looking forward to this
would like to know what they have been
up to yeah I know I am so interested to
see what what they were up to well
what's happening with infinity war so
I'm so curious I have some ideas about
what might happen at the end but I can't
share it because boilers I'm sorry but
hit me on my social media and said we
don't have to wait too long that comes
out July 6 and I'm looking forward to
also this week we got a fun Deadpool
Celine Dion team-up on a music video of
sorts the song was called ashes and it
was a really hilarious but also
beautiful and well done promo for
Deadpool to perfect that dancing in the
heels I really really really want to
know if that was really actually Ryan
Reynolds I doubt it was but still I want
it to be oh well that and that's why
there the mask exists so that we can
just live with that
it was Deadpool whether or not it was
Ryan Reynolds it was dead well that's
what what matters I think there's even
like the line that Deadpool says at the
end like Celine Dion that was beautiful
but we have to take down a notch because
it was like a - oh I love that that
they're saying like man guys
expectations are way too high for this
you are at 11 you need me like 5 this is
Deadpool - it's hilarious it seems like
Celine Dion was even excited to be a
part of it right I was wondering if she
even knew what this was like going into
it I'm sure she must have she might have
but it was a great team of had no idea I
needed that in my life right and every
time you think Deadpool has outdone
themselves on their promo department we
get another gem we only have to wait
until May 18th right and I'm 11 days in
other superhero news this week DC has
finally announced the name of its
streaming service are you ready I'm
ready
it's DC Universe oh yeah ok yeah I mean
that's already a term in use though
right it's just a really confusing
choice I think there's so many other
things that involves the DC Universe
like how are you gonna talk about it
turn yeah comics right in the DC
Universe all wait the surimi service and
the DC Cinematic Universe like it it
just seems very confusing unless they're
rebranding everything to condense it all
into one because I have been calling
this an interactive fan experience so
who knows many they are literally
condensing everything into one area but
well that would be really strange I
don't know I thought this was kind of an
odd choice season what who knows maybe
it'll make sense when they move forward
and with this announcement of the name
also came an announcement that there's
going to be a Swamp Thing show happening
on the streaming service and it sounds
really good it involves some of the
writers of daredevil and it's so I think
the tone will be right
like the good shows and a good movies so
if they have that same kind of writing
genre to what it is really good and then
James one who is an executive producer
who is also working with Aquaman right
now has went on Twitter and announced it
and said that you can expect a lot of
mood mystery gothic romance and of
course swamp monster it's a sign me this
could work really well especially if it
has kind of like a Hellboy Eska tone to
it there's that for some success here so
we'll we've added that to the roster now
of the DC streaming service DC Universe
so now we've got Titans Young Justice
Harley Quinn and the Swamp Thing series
all confirmed for this so we'll have to
wait until 2019 to see what's going on
at some point I'm sure they'll be news
exactly one yeah um also this week we
are getting hyped for solo a Star Wars
story
um they released a couple of things this
week first thing they released is a tour
that Donald Glover led of Lando's
Millennium Falcon and so hopefully it's
so sparkly and beautiful we haven't wife
and can't just you know speck of Jesse
did you say if you haven't seen it you
should go check it out um because it's
really fun it's only like a minute and
45 seconds but it's really fun we get to
go around and see all the different
areas it seems like the set is really
stylized yeah to look like a new hope
kind of like rogue one was which is
obviously works really well with the
continuation of the Star Wars universe
it looks pretty cool
it's just so cute dr. Glover is so
excited still to be a part of this like
he doesn't do a lot of hype hype hype
stuff but he's still super chill but you
can tell he's just loved being on the
set and I love that you can feel that
coming from it so you should definitely
check that out um they also released a
little clip of Chewie becoming the
copilot so I am holding out some hope
for this it seems like it's gonna be the
fun campy Star Wars nothing that's gonna
be too edgy or different kind of what I
would expect from Ron Howard doing me
Star Wars movie yeah and that's coming
out on May 25th yeah we also got a
little fun new hope Arrested Development
parody as well which was of course
narrated by Ron Howard as well and
there's a bunch of fun Star Wars
references from a new hope specifically
but also like Arrested Development like
heroes blood oh so good so good it was
really thinking of Arrested Development
though we got the season for Roberto
remix on Cinco de cuatro Cinco de floss
perfect timing and a little bit of
announcement that season 5 is coming
soon yeah real soon that's what the
announcement said and I'm assuming
because of the remix that season 5 is
going to be back to the original kind of
layout of the show kind of a similar
tone the remix is really good I
recommend watching it I also watched
season 4 when it first came out so right
I'm excited for more Arrested
Development who is it but that's all we
have time for today anything else that
we might let us know in the comments
down below or you can always hit up
either of us on social media Heather
where is that for you you can find me on
Twitter at Heather roost Instagram at a
truce or twitch twitch TV slash how the
roofs were a storm on Wednesday nights
yeah and you can find me on Facebook as
I on away or everywhere else as awesome
Ayana we'll catch you tomorrow on top 5
otherwise you can catch us next week
same time same place
in the meantime can you beam us up
[Applause]
you